legit confirmed hogwarts legacy news we
actually have a little bit today and
hopefully fingers crossed even more
later this week people of the internet
retroarch and tour here and as you all
know the game awards are happening this
week there are plenty of rumors out
there that hogwarts legacy will make an
appearance at the show but before we get
to the rumors we actually have some
concrete totally 100 legit news to
discuss i know it's kind of nice right
so here it is guys avalanche has finally
made their hire for the game's community
manager and it's a gentleman by the name
of chandler wood professor quirrell
excuse me excuse could i borrow wood for
a moment please
oh yeah yes of course he made the
announcement on twitter and also was
kind enough to respond to a question of
mine asking which house he belongs to
and unfortunately as a gryffindor that
is i do have to confirm the answer was
slytherin looking a bit into his
background you can see he's the former
editor-in-chief at playstation lifestyle
and he was with the website for nine
years so he's certainly someone who's
well versed in the video game industry
on the editorial side especially it'll
be interesting to see what he brings to
the table for hogwarts legacy and what
we hope is an upcoming marketing
campaign and that's part of the reason
honestly guys that i think this is a
pretty exciting moment for hogwarts lexi
because this really helps set the stage
for future marketing and hopefully wb
getting more news out about the game it
makes total sense that avalanche would
want to have this person in place before
they make that big marketing push as
that as a person who would certainly be
very involved in any sort of marketing
plan for the game now if you've been
following the game for a while you know
this is a position that avalanche has
been looking to fill for quite some time
we've seen it posted a couple of times i
actually went back and tried to find
when the original listing was posted and
the one that i found was all the way
back in july of this year and if you
look at you can go on and google it now
and find it but in the job description
it says quote the community manager will
act as the voice of the game to the
players while representing the voice of
the players to the game team they will
engage players in conversations on
forums and social channels and will
support the creation of community
content such as faqs live streams and
guides so going by that right there i
think this is someone we should clearly
expect to see and hear from quite often
on forums the hp game subreddit and
maybe even youtube channels in fact i'd
love to have chandler on the channel
here at some point if you guys would
like to see a video like that happen
give this one a thumbs up to show them
how much we want to see that happen now
we realize he is just starting out the
job so it may take him a while to get
familiar with things get a plan in place
for how he wants to go about interacting
with community i'm sure he's going to
have meetings with their marketing folks
with the game folks with everyone at
avalanche to figure out how best they're
going to market and sort of build this
community around hogwarts legacy and
i've mentioned this briefly in some
other videos before but i want to kind
of expand on it a bit more here
typically when we think of community
managers you think of large multiplayer
games typically ongoing multiplayer
games i mean things like fortnite
destiny and call of duty and i've looked
around online i have found some for
single player games but really it's just
not something you see all that often and
so part of me thinks now again i've
talked already about how i think there's
going to be a secret multiplayer mode
for this game maybe we even find out
about that later this week i don't know
but i think there's going to be some
element even if it's all let's just say
it is 100 single player like they've
said so far i do think there is going to
be some sort of ongoing element or maybe
dlcs in the future maybe story updates
just something to warrant the need for a
community manager like this i mean think
back to that quote from avalanche i mean
engaging players in conversations on
forums and social channels they're
wanting to support community content
which i think is absolutely awesome and
they also talked about how he will be
the voice of the game team to the
players but also how he will be our
voice back to the game team which to me
i mean why in a single player game or a
game that's just you know sort of a
static single player experience would
you really need a lot of extensive
feedback unless you had some sort of
long-term plan for keeping this game
updated keeping it fresh keeping it
going with new content so again maybe
it's multiplayer maybe it's something
else maybe it's some other content that
they're going to be adding and kind of
continuously updating along the way i
don't know but i'm really excited to see
where this goes now as i teased in the
beginning of the video it is possible we
all know the game awards are right
around the corner and look if you're a
hogwarts legacy fan if you've been
following the game for any length of
time we've been here before a big event
on the horizon and we're all like maybe
this is the one maybe this is it guys
maybe this is the moment when we get
more information now before when we were
talking about chandler that is a
concrete definitive thing this is much
more nebulous all we have are some
teases i know millie a had the post on
twitter honestly i wasn't even gonna
make a video about that at all because
i'm just like over those little rumors
at this point but once this news dropped
then there was also a wb france tweet
that was deleted so they basically just
retweeted one of jeff keeley's posts
about the game awards and had the little
eye emoji you guys know the one just
kind of like oh what's up what's what's
going on with this you know like get
your eyeballs on this pay attention to
this and it was actually deleted but
again wb has a number of games coming
out so it doesn't necessarily mean it's
hogwarts legacy but when you take all
three of these things into account the
melee a the supposed hogwarts legacy
leaker or insider i guess not really so
much a leaker but insider on the game
that wb france tweet and then the hiring
of this community manager maybe just
maybe we get something new on the game
at the game awards i mean just how
insane is it you guys we are in the
month of december now the game was
delayed all the way back in january we
thought we would have it in our hands by
this moment and instead we've went the
entire year without a peep i mean
without so much of a peep from these
guys now i do want to caution you even
if the game awards come and go and we
hear absolutely nothing yes we'll all be
disappointed but i don't think we should
just be you know incredibly like drop
everything this game is never coming out
i'm so over it i don't think we should
take drastic measures because the hiring
of this community manager having that
person in place i think is a really good
sign and also tells us something a
little bit about their timeline now that
they've got this person in place they've
certainly got a huge marketing team they
may even be using an outside marketing
company to kind of help wb to promote
this game there's just a ton of stuff
going on around harry potter right now
we've got the reunion coming up on
january 1st if you haven't heard about
that that's a really big deal in the
harry potter community right now we've
got that new trivia show i don't know if
you guys have seen this it's it's
actually pretty cool my wife and i were
watching it i thought the questions were
a little bit too easy and the difficult
ones were just kind of annoyingly
difficult ones like look at this random
spot on the floor and do you remember
which scene this from that stuff's kind
of annoying but for the most part i
actually enjoyed the show so you got
that you got the new fantastic beasts
movie all this stuff is just coming
together at the right time for 2022 to
be an absolutely huge year for hogwarts
legacy so guys and gals hopefully we
will hear more from chandler soon on the
game in the meantime if you're new here
check out my harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban let's play list here
on the right side of your channel
actually i've played through the first
three games at this point so if you're
in the mood check those out or if you
want more hogwarts legacy content then
check out the video on the left side of
your screen right now as always thank
you all so much for watching and i will
talk to you again soon